it's the second deadliest form of cancer
in the UK but a new survey suggests two
in five of us can't name any symptoms do
you know what we're talking about
well joy and I buy a Survivor Susie
Smith who was 32 when she was diagnosed
with bowel cancer and she's all clear
I'm all clear yeah as of two weeks ago
so very very fresh thank you
congratulations we've seen you ringing
the bell to say that you're cancer-free
tell us about your story yes so um
unfortunately I had symptoms for about
18 months so that's why I'm here today
so hopefully people can learn from my
mistakes so I had I'm you know the
poster child so I had significant weight
loss I was extremely tired
um significant boating I also
um
was going to the toilet rapidly and then
of course you know what bow babe taught
us
um was that I definitely did have who in
my I had blood in my stool
um so I needed to to check check the
check the toilet at the time you just
you just thought oh I'm too busy and
yeah I think it was you know living in
London living in a pandemic I'm 32
um you know you could always put it down
to something else yeah and like I did go
to a doctor and unfortunately I was told
that I had piles
um and you know when you hear you've got
piles you run out of there okay and you
know you presume it's something else and
I was running and I was in therapy and I
was meditating and doing everything I
could to feel better but unfortunately I
had something in me that I needed
obviously to take away so what happened
uh so it was in September of 2021
um and I was having dinner with my best
friend and I was just
crying into my food and at this stage I
had no idea what was going on I just was
like this is no longer life stress this
is no longer anything that I can explain
like this is an exhaustion that I was
hardly able to get to my favorite Pub
and she looked at me and she just said
okay I think it's maybe time for a
doctor like I'm sure there's nothing
going on but let's just get a little
colonoscopy and my best friend literally
saved my life so two weeks after that I
saw a doctor said all my symptoms quite
quickly and for the first time I got
like a ping of urgency of like again
probably nothing wrong but like let's
get let's get this checked out and then
got a colonoscopy and I there was
in a robe eating ice cream and was told
that I had cancer so what stage cancer
stage three
amazing then what happened and then what
happened was so 18 very long months so
had 12 rounds of chemotherapy I then had
25 rounds to raise your hair I didn't
lose my hair so about babes usually
don't so I did lose a lot in the front
yeah um because my first six chemo
sessions were incredibly tough
um but no my hair held on so here we are
today with my curls well done thank you
and um and then I had to have radiation
so 25 rounds of radiation and chemo
together which was very tough and left
me with a lot of life-changing impacts
unfortunately and then I had to have an
operation which left me with a stroma
bag three weeks later I had to go in
again they found five centimeters more
cancer so that was a operation that I
didn't plan for which was also
incredibly tough and then I had six more
rounds of chemotherapy and I'm very
happy to say that two weeks ago that I
had my stroma bag removed
yeah so here I am making my noise and it
was very emotional actually walk into
the studio to see that picture and to
remember that do you feel lucky
I feel incredible amounts of gratitude
like I think lucky is a tough word I
think obviously I've had a really tough
time and I think I will get to Lucky but
I know how fortunate I am I know that
this is not the case for everybody I
know that I had a very Advanced cancer
so I feel gratitude that I had an
incredible team gratitude for the
medicine that was able to fix me
gratitude for my family gratitude for
bowel cancer UK who was able to support
me and I think as I work hard there will
be a luck that I know that I can move
forward and what advice would you give
to people watching at home who have
cancer or who potentially have some
symptoms so I'm not sure they're a bit
out of sorts and they're not sure okay
well I think definitely if you feel like
you've got any of the symptoms that I
mentioned today that you deserve to be
healthy so I think that's the big thing
that I want people to learn from my
mistakes is that there's no point
sitting and having your head in the sand
like just go and get the answers go fix
it like bowel cancer is one of those
cancers that if it is caught early that
you can survive that is a really high
survival rate and you won't need as much
treatment as me so get your answers
knowledge is power and if you are
unfortunately living with cancer at the
moment I think my biggest thing that I
learned was that you really need to find
light like it's your choice every
morning you can wait and obviously I
didn't do this every morning there were
some mornings that I you know were dark
and I rolled over and I watched Married
at First Night yeah um we are out of
time okay but my goodness me what a
story and you look Sensational thanks
for joining us see you in just a second
here on Sky